well hello there burrowing owl aren't
you cute yes yes you are what with your
fluffy down and your round face and wait
what you you have fleas a lot of fleas
okay yeah yeah so you feed on rodents
and then you take over their burrows yes
yes I've heard that ground squirrels do
have a lot of fleas wait seriously the
fleas carry the plague like wiped out
millions of humans black death that
plague uh-huh so what on earth are those
field biologists doing holding you and
your plague-ridden please oh they're
studying why you don't get the play well
that's sort of a really so why don't you
get to play ah no one knows for sure but
the scientists at Boise State in Idaho
they're the people holding you they did
some research and found it while the
fleas feed on you ouch you don't seem to
get infected and that may actually be
taking the plate please out of
circulation because they hang out on you
and aren't jumping on to other species
like humans right right or the ground
squirrels that periodically die off in
massive plagues that could result of the
human infection well that's pretty neat
especially given that you're kind of
endangered so more of you might be a
good thing to curb the plague great
you